hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters ok we just
got a key a key to what I'm not exactly
sure but um I'm wondering I got through
to this area again I know there are
things in the sky up there so ah maybe
this oh dang it lock is jammed ok that
was not it that's not it either
oh boy ah ok we trying just hop lick
epic dodge not know ok um steady right
either ah damn it [ __ ] those things can
I just shoot him out of the sky Oh screw
you buddy you're you're stupid sound aah
no
well that took way too much ammo crackle
there we go God see ah no no whoo whoops
okay right now those are dead I don't
know if I needed to do that but I got
the key there must have been a reason
lock is jammed there by this bush nope
okay ah it's you oh go away I might be
going the wrong way again oh oh okay I
know I came through here before and I
went in here to kill the big face guy
but then I think I'm just going in one
big circle and not the circle I was
supposed to go let me just try
everything because I want to make sure
that I cover all the bases before I
commit to making a mistake
all right back in here I got a key I've
got the keys to section D and I've got
the keys good you down there no I've got
the key to something something else it
just unlocked the gate that allowed me
to get back so maybe I need to backtrack
a bit more as in go back towards the way
I came there is a possibility there
shouldn't be any monsters here I should
have cleared him out or ran away from
him or something ah here yeah this is um
this is the building where I was snow
only ah there's something in there I
know I remember I did not kill it and if
I go down here this is where the spiders
were yeah this is this area and there
was nothing in this all that might be a
fatal wound oh boy yeah okay so
and this wasn't open okay let me load
back up the game I had in the beginning
since that was before I wasted the ammo
is before I did anything stupid so maybe
the idea is I go back this way and I'll
be able to go where I need to go
maybe then again maybe not I really
don't know why dammit nope apparently
not well what the hell then why do I
have this key what does this key do huh
dammit
um I really don't know how could this
key before I thought I'd just unlock
this one but maybe not maybe there's
something else up here no II know
okay there's still the monsters in there
maybe that's something else in there
that I missed let's go look get away
[ __ ] hey halt
get away okay don't think there was
anything oh whoa whoa whoa man
they're everywhere ah here nope that was
a lie
alright oh man
okay apparently there's nothing over
here but maybe maybe I should check out
that room upstairs where there was an
enemy that I did not kill I know I
didn't kill it because it killed me
before so let me check it out where are
you where are you ha there is a hallway
oh that's where you guys came from -
hakufu ah what what what baloney what a
heck of a Loney are you gonna get the
super powerful kaboom or I'm gonna miss
what oh god how did the second one get
by me why am I so bad at this or
whatever charge him ha boom pop boom pop
boom what the hell how are you this
tough you are not this tough before this
is [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you and [ __ ] your face
even though you don't have a fight there
we go one down nope there that took two
shots I'm beginning to think that all of
the enemies have a variable amount of
health and it's just screwing with me
okay now down here see what we got
aha
there we are jet oh right [ __ ] blue
button there was a blue power button
outside maybe that has something to do
with that yeah I remember
okay I just got to get by the big guy
how'd you get in huh ah no oh
lepak elite skills damn it you're just
gonna stay right there aren't you I'm
running on a battery life are you still
there okay whatever excuse me pardon me
sorry excuse me just making my way
around you okay
aha yep that was it all right in here
okay I'm in cool what's down there
anything nothing a lot of nothing okay
ah god damn it ah-ha
[ __ ] down to three health again [ __ ]
alright what did that ah well at least
that counted got me back my health I'm
not gonna quick load every time because
I just G fancy experience life [ __ ] up
and get hit and I [ __ ] up and I got
hit I'm not gonna reload there you are
whoa you're quick
there we go all right where did that guy
come from
did he just spawn okay all right Fred I
got the red but I don't remember where a
red door was go ah don't block the
doorway you [ __ ] you know let me see
if I can cut him up come on come on
ah he's right there Cup there we go okay
ha ha user I'm a do best and this is
taking forever okay not yet yeah wow
that took a lot
wait what's over here what's up here oh
yes please come through that door
ah whoa what the hell oh whoops I looked
away before I got the full brunt of that
but whatever wouldn't have scared me
anyway okay all right look clear sorta
clear okay now I bet I'm supposed to go
back and find a red door ah the red door
of course whoa do I see something I may
be I'm sometimes I think I see something
but I'm probably not real
handy and head up brightly lit I like it
it's probably gonna go out let's go out
first
nope argh
it's locked me matey we're pirates now
whoa
this seems out of ordinary out of the
ordinary is right grandpa would say
there a head guy hidin anywhere in here
ah what was that I saw something
ah no pills yes please seriously I need
a better melee weapon than a frickin
night come on it's half life give me a
crowbar ah nothing okay that was all the
goodies I got some pistol ammo which I'm
happy for and this is way too bright
water Oh
I like this is bright but I don't like
it what was that
hey the waters movement that's cool
haha oh my goodness
oh-oh-oh-oh hammer yes hammer it's slow
but I bet it hits hard all right let's
give it a try oh no no no no no no Oh
get me up get me up get me up get me up
give me uh oh
hello huh what how do I get out oh I get
it I just jump up on the side okay let's
try this hammer come here hmm hmm no not
yet yeah there we go three hits that's
more like it
that's the stuff of nightmares it's
blocked from the other side pop hello
open up on the rail because I'm cheating
it's not cheating I argue with myself
whack the screen shake cool I like it
hey buddy how's it going my computer
doesn't seem to be handling the water
too well come back
why'd you go back over there come here
come here
all right I'll try to fight this guy
straight up huh map nope that's the one
wow that guy's extra twitchy that guy's
extra fast and extra twitchy okay I
won't try to fight that guy straight up
come here come here come here come come
all right stay there
hi what the hell you want me to go over
there we rampu huh boo boo yeah
what is this you're leashing for Al [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you know miss me and that
guy was like super spazzy goodness the
detonator is on the third floor what oh
why would I need to blow it up oh no
walk
so how do i oh you're back how the heck
how the heck did you I mean what your
different one
is so slow hammer Oh
one shot yeah they all do have variable
health there's no way it's all the same
all right damn it
okay um there was that staircase but the
door I couldn't get through up top got
to be something else that I'm missing
that one was blocked on the outside
excuse me
and I got through here but what did this
do I don't think it did anything
enough maybe it turned off some steam
somewhere upstairs I don't know oh no go
away
you twitchy bastard oh you got some
writing on your for it I can barely see
it but there it is
okay alright going back upstairs I don't
know what that super great is all about
on the third floor upstairs this be the
second this would be the aha the button
open the door okay all right let's see
what we got here
HUP oh hello boo what's this acetone
I remember using a lot of acetone Ian
o-chem hello goodbye come on take your
yeah there we go
still twitchy don't be touchy I missed
me
oh yeah pwnage to the extreme okay
that's a good note and anon I got Andy
here thank you guys so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the neck
art bye bye